I'm really matter I know Becca's
honestly upset about the lack of honesty
and we're honestly surprisingly falling
for wills it's time for roses and Rosie
hey you guys let's start off with some
positivity Ashley and Jared are engaged
Ashley iock and Eddie and Jared hey Ben
- I never know how to say his last name
Jared I love you are engaged you guys
the new sub aditya and calm along with
several wonderfully gushy interviews
that I did with them and they are the
sweetest and Wow love love honest love
cheers to it back to the Bachelorette we
are here of course to recap Becca Cooper
in season The Bachelorette so we start
off this episode with the cocktail party
because we didn't see it at the end of
last week's episode so you know it's
been laughs and oz it's been a long week
what is his name does anyone know has he
spoken at all I talk to God every day
and people who go against me just end up
first sometimes of course they're
talking about David falling out of a
bunk bed and clay getting his wrist hurt
and having to drop out
Blake has something actually
substantives to say he is going to try
to cheer Becca up so they have a cute
little moment off to the side on a weird
like mo colored bedspread whatever and
Blake just starts talking about how many
kids she wants to have I think three and
Wow is this a great grounded
conversation type like for bachelor I'm
just saying I don't know if it doesn't
we'll see what
Bingle color and I'm not wearing a tie
with it so it kind of shows her like
okay this guy like he'd go either way
right now and then Jordan is wearing
some kind of shirtless shirt tie with a
collar tie shirt up and down tie it's
weak it sucked situation and he is
confusing I talk to God everyday people
they go against me just end up her
sometimes looks like I'm the golden boy
right now I think that guy might have my
groin on her mind it fells like victory
David is back after a casual moment in
the ICU have you ever seen an intensive
care unit situation 188 like this before
I guess he was you know allegedly in the
ICU Colin Becca stain what's up and now
he's back and he seems a little out of
it I do wonder if he's on pain meds
which I would understand because his
face is pretty messed up we don't really
find out exactly what the injuries were
it looks like you maybe broke his nose
I've got a black eye cheers to David but
not cheers to David because I don't
really like anything he had to say I'm
here tonight Rebecca and Beck only and
maybe the noise or in a little bit what
he's getting I thought that I would have
all this sympathy for him when he came
back but I'm actually liking him less
because of the way that he's approaching
coming back
he's saying a lot of weird crap and if
you were here to annoy Jordan then man
is it time to straighten out your
priorities David gets a rose jordan
calls it friends and whoa guys drink
every time you agree with Jordan this
episode I stand with Jordan on this that
did feel like a pity rose I don't blame
Becca but it's not like one it's very
hard for me to get nervous about the
Rose ceremonies anymore is this just me
give me your thoughts in the comments I
am not worried about who's gonna go home
I don't know a lot of these guys I'm
much more captivated by the one-on-ones
and the rest of what's going on I think
we need an update on the rose ceremony
somehow way in now we find that they're
going to Park City Utah does this mean
more sports
please don't on it mean more sports they
keep talking about how it's really
outdoorsy there I can't watch any more
sports I realized why this season has
felt so sports heavy because not only do
they do sports related activities which
is normal and typical and great but we
have like two football players that take
a basketball player like there's just
there's also a lot of I guess you'd call
them athletes and then Utah Garrett gets
the first one-on-one and man did we see
how much Becca likes carrots she says
she just makes me feel like that
couldn't be me and be my goofy self
which if you remember is something that
she really liked about Arie
she says she's so attracted to him she
says you remind me of my dad a little
bit these are very important things very
important things I like these cuts
between the deepness of the one-on-one
and the hilariousness of what's going on
back at the house where all the guys are
because we find out that Lincoln doesn't
think that the earth is round the earth
is flat
Lincoln says it's flat I just personally
think I didn't know evidence I don't
know how to say this
Lincoln thinks the earth is flat he
thinks that friction is what's holding
us all up here do you know why you can
walk in that sleep off position yes and
he thinks the earth is flat maybe what
is that wise in a foreign down I'm not
gonna say let me know your thoughts in
the comments because the earth is round
guys it's round so that's that if you
missed the news you can get a d-10 line
calm and basically it has come out that
Lincoln was arrested and has a criminal
past and still somehow made it onto the
show and has been convicted of a crime
so that is very problematic and I don't
know what else to say about it it's
obviously some kind of mistake
and obviously something needs to be
addressed so these mistakes don't happen
again in the future
and it's very unfortunate and I feel bad
for Becca
so Garrett and Becca are gonna go
bobsledding and they're like oh my gosh
are we having the most perfect date
right now and like yes this is another
problem with the franchise you are
having a perfect date right now you're
on a TV show and you don't win when you
get off the TV show whatever
relationship Becca ends up in she's
gonna have to find a way to ground it I
think we need to do some kind of date
that's really a struggle you know where
the bobsledding isn't handed to someone
some kind of survivor type date like
leave them on a desert island for a hot
minute and see what happens you know
that's the way to get to know somebody
is when you got to find a way to get
water
you guys have watch naked and afraid
oh my gosh seeing and naked and afraid'
bachelor/bachelorette crossover date in
the future and I'm I keep saying that
this is reverse dating where you put
everything out on the table right away I
really like how with Becca season
they're kind of breaking the fourth wall
a little bit and acknowledging the
process Becca has several times said to
guys like you need to open up quickly
for us to move forward here and she
tells Garrett so what were your past
relationship anyone was the most
recently and we find out Garrett was
married for two months only two months
that's not a great story but he says
he's here for Becca and he's moved on it
was two years ago he's ready for love
okay everybody makes mistakes here we go
that's all we can do is take him at his
word that's all we've got in this
process honesty on the journey then the
group date it's a lumberjack date so not
totally a sport drink every time it
wasn't totally a sport is pop sledding
totally a sport I guess it's an Olympic
thing okay well whatever mm-hmm choose
to drink here we go you know at 14 girls
we're falling for Leonardo DiCaprio I
was falling through the lumberjacks
so Becca says that when people like me
were into leo she was in the Lumberjacks
what what what that's not dis Leo he's a
heartthrob of America then you have guys
like George not necessarily an
outdoorsman he showed his true colors in
the spot really good with their posh
really good with nail polish David slams
Jordan again saying his big insult was
the Jordan knows how to paint nails well
but I stand with Jordan Jordan knew also
how to chop a log in half some
surprising guys did great on the st.
John the cute little engineer who I
think claimed he invented venmo which I
don't think is really true he did great
he was super sweet you did so well John
got the golden axe which isn't a rose
but whatever and Jason was cracking me
up I mean that guy's in the middle of
Utah and he looks like a cast member of
the original Wall Street
Lucian has become real he's got his like
New Yorker full-length brown coat on his
hair slicked back and he's like these
guys are all done cinterion freaking
luggage he's really pretty funny I like
Jason and I like that he acknowledged
I'm scared
ain't that okay I had such a fun time at
Jason and back to have a cute moment she
says he's a very good kisser
and I believed her because they zoomed
in so much and his pace did look good
the thing is Becca says a couple times
that like things are going so well and
I'm just having a really really good
time and when things are going so well
or they're saying they're going so well
that's foreshadowing isn't literary term
that they're gonna not go so well quite
soon because we've got a show to make
here so rather surprisingly Colton also
can friends Jordan do your walking
around and go
undies and and I'm rather shocked and
you know what I agree with Jordan if no
one's talking about respect why is he
calling Jordan these terrible names
again okay cuz that's just that you talk
about disrespecting you just call me I
stand with Jordan I decided to get you a
gift yeah it's kind of like one of my
passions
Jean Blanc who I sort of forgot about
gives her a custom perfume which I sort
of forgot perfume and cologne was his
thing and then he says I'm truly falling
for you and I'm falling in love with you
what what no don't do that
that guy's like I don't know if I'm on
that same page and she sends him home
should I walk you out and then he tries
to backtrack what about the gift he's
like well I only said that because I
thought you wanted to hear that
obviously this guy caught up got caught
up in the show in the moment and that
Becca's very upset and she just wants
honesty she just wants honesty didn't
you watch Ari's manali by by Jean Blanc
smell you later she sends him home and
then we get a breath of fresh Utah air
wills wills will you keep being this
awesome he was great on this one-on-one
he was easy and fun and kind and
grounding and man the other guys are
really relying on him before they left
before he left
they were like wills needs to bring us
back home here cuz John Blanc really
threw back off and he did he was just
calm and easy and sexy and open and
vulnerable and honest about the journey
and the journey was through some snow
and you Tom thank God a sport wasn't
involved in I really like whales mmm so
some surprised guys were at that time
where some of the middling guys are
gonna move to the front of the pack or
fall and go home and Will's and Jason
and even John a little bit we're kind of
moving forward for me this week Conor
then we get another rose ceremony and a
guy who were tracksuit earlier in this
episode and the athlete the Harlem
Globetrotter guy go home so bye is the
blind man one guy still there I was
looking for an event I I don't know what
happened to if anybody knows please let
me know in the comments I really don't
know I never knew his name and I don't
know if he saw the show or not I've
never ever made it last place than
anything in my entire life
I'm much like a sponge you can squeeze
me and get everything out of me but
you'll never know unless you try that's
life so next week everybody they are
going to Vegas I'm not into this Vegas
is a weird city I've never spent more
than two days there and even in those
two days it felt too long I'm just not a
fan I would have rather had some more
amazing sexy champagne outdoor hot tub
moments in Utah I don't even think we've
got an outdoor hot tub which I love when
they do in cold weather it's my dream so
Vegas we'll see what happens I have to
look out for myself
and it seems like Chris is gonna take a
turn for the worst next week which
usually happens when someone gets an
early one-on-one and then they don't get
a lot of time with the person for a
while they get in their head
Blake is really holding it down staying
calm in that regard by the way who are
you guys liking at this point so let me
know what you guys thought also of the
Lincoln issue and man it's been a couple
of scandals already Rebecca this season
and I feel bad for her but she's staying
strong through it all and yeah thank you
guys so much for watching
will's bye Eve